[Musique]
donc avant
toute cette zone était dénudée il n'y avait
pas d'arbres il n'y avait rien ici
mais maintenant si vous regardez
vous pouvez voir de grands arbres
revenir donc il y a une très
grande différence
[Musique]
la relation entre les
plantes indigènes et le
café
est que  le café pousse très bien sous le
hangar
et
la communauté a détruit
cette
montagne gorongosa donc nous avons un objectif
de
reboiser donc avec le café nous avons
beaucoup de succès [
Musique]
nous faisons avec les communautés tout autour de
la montagne de euh cerra gorongosa est-
ce  nous les intéressons au reboisement
grâce à des revenus supplémentaires
créant des revenus supplémentaires grâce au
café mais aussi à la culture intercalaire avec d'autres
cultures pendant que le café pousse
nous avons une production de
bananes et nous avons une production de
grains pendant que le café atteint la
première année de production qui
prend généralement trois  ans
[Musique]
toi